okay
stand by we're going live
are you out of your mind here's the
debate
all right episode number 146 with the
legendary david berlinski if you don't
know our guest today let me give him a
proper introduction i give him a
different one off camera i'm going to
give that as well just just so you know
i made that commitment to you i'm going
to do it okay senior fellow of the
discovery institute center for science
and uh culture the hub of intelligent
design movement
uh he uh i want to say he got his phd in
philosophy from princeton
and uh was also was a fellow in
mathematics and molecular biology at
columbia university but he doesn't stop
there he's taught philosophy mathematics
english at stanford rutgers uh the city
of new uh university of new york uh
university of washington university of
uh boujee sound san jose state
university this university santa clara
university of san francisco san
francisco state university mathematics
at university de paris and he flew in
from paris which the flight was
uneventful and here's what i told you
off-camera and i want to say to
everybody as well you come across as the
man that uh you've debated hitchens
you've you've you've shared a stage with
some of the best debaters hitches being
on the atheist side you went up there on
the agnostic side
you've gone against darwinism you've
gone against i don't know sam harris
you've you you have a lot of different
opinions but you're sarcastic you have a
sense of humor you know how to poke you
know how to get under people's skins and
you're very very smart with that being
said david thank you so much for
traveling come and visit us here in
florida
you're so very welcome it's a pleasure
being here yes and it's a pleasure
having you and i love that tie you got
it yeah
well dressed as well i mean above all
sharp i bought you intellectual life in
terms of the opportunity it affords me
to display my wardrobe that's what it is
i like that so this you really only came
to show off your clothes
the only thing about the conversation
the only reason let's just do a fashion
show right now let me imagine so hey why
did you go on that guy's podcast listen
i wanted to show the new timings
we spent five minutes talking about his
shoes before the podcast yeah there's no
reason to stop that conversation
you know what forget about god forget
about evolution forget about darwinism i
told you turn this into a fascist i told
him listen you're you would be would you
call yourself a confused jew why would
you put yourself out yeah yeah i'll tell
you that you know christian what would
you put yourself catholic confused
catholic and then we have a you know
agnostic over here what would you
consider yourself tyler
confused jew i think
tyler is not jewish whatsoever but he's
talking about converting but he's
confused regardless i told here's the
expectation i don't like to start
podcasts with a very high expectation
where we're going to be disappointing
ourselves today we're going to start off
with a very
low
expectation the goal is by the time we
are done
we know for a fact who got us that's
what the goal is it's not a high
expectation and we've got some i don't
like you that can help us with that
uh obviously the weekend's been very
eventful i was in uh we haven't done a
podcast this week i was uh friday i went
to joe roach and watched him perform in
jacksonville which was hilarious and i
saw tony tony hinchcliffe oh my god oh
so i thought you just went to a ufc you
actually know that i was with joe stand
up he got me tickets and i want to watch
them perform he
i had no idea this guy was this funny
joe 12 000 people in rooms perform in
the middle in the back a full-on fight
breaks out 20 people rumble
it's hilar everyone's looking at it
they're screaming joe's like what the
hell is going on back there they put the
light in that section and you literally
see like you know guys punching another
guy they all stop and sit down because
they didn't want to get arrested cops
ran up there it was awesome the next day
we went to the fight we had dinner two
nights together with joe and tony and
hans and you know all the guys just a
bunch of mans man
freaking awesome conversations a lot of
good things coming soon the restaurant
we went to is cal ford steakhouse the
owner sent me a message saying i've been
watching your content for the longest
time the most ridiculous steakhouse in
jacksonville bone marrow
fogra
wagyu beef they brought everything the
dessert was ridiculous we had a good
time i'll fill in on a major project
that we may be launching here soon
that's going to be very funny
and it's going to be for men stick
around we'll be announcing it probably
next
i don't know maybe tomorrow if not
definitely next week and uh it's going
to be fun but we went from rogan to the
house that brady built oh we ran into mr
berlin yeah we rented out the entire
foxboro
stadium and we brought uh two patriots
one was uh matt uh light who's hilarious
he was the offensive line the center for
brady he was telling story he won three
super bowls himself and he's in the new
england patriots hall of fame and then
uh we had uh rob uh nikovich ninkovic
which is
linebacker linebacker beast number 50.
absolute both of them went to uh purdue
then uh uh tom's uh agent was their
manager was financial the guy who's been
managing his finances for the last 17
years he was there we sat there and
watched man in the arena for two days it
was a great session we had a great time
but today is about
you so
for some that don't know if you don't
mind taking a minute and give your
background on how you got started
why mathematics
how you came to your conclusion with
your philosophy try to do that in a you
know shorter version and then we'll go
into questions and different topics sure
essential aspects born 1942 new york mid
manhattan
and no matter how many different places
i live i'll always be a new yorker
that's inerratical
i went through public schools in new
york went to bronx science then i went
to columbia and then i went to princeton
for a phd
after that i went out to stanford as an
assistant professor and
thereafter i decided i had a higher
calling than
an academic life and so i did a lot of
different things i worked for mckinsey
for a year
i worked for the city of new york god
only knows how i got a job as a senior
budgetary analyst
they gave me two billion dollars and
said spend it carefully on the welfare
of the city of 2 billion what year is
this what year is it this was 1970 or
71. that's a lot of money 2 billion oh
yeah it went so fast
perhaps the worst decision of the
lindsay administration to put that kind
of money in my hands i had no idea what
to do with it except to spend it as
rapidly as possible and then i bounced
around in a lot of different academic
positions spent some time at columbia
taught for a while at rutgers moved out
to california lived in san francisco
taught up and down silicon valley and
various colleges switched from teaching
philosophy and logic to teaching
mathematics
i love teaching mathematics especially
the calculus sequence
and then around 1992 i figured i'm going
to live just by writing and that's what
pretty much i've been doing ever since
99 i left the united states moved to
france
and i've been in paris for the last 25
years very happily ensconced right next
to notre dame oh
so i'm the beneficiary of a lot of
wisdom coming from the cathedral
and if it's worth your while to answer
your own questions
i'm prepared to discuss the issue so why
why paris why did you want to live there
why have you been there for 25 years
because the united states was a little
too small for me and my ex-wives
how many ex-wives was that sufficiently
many
okay sufficiently many right that was
the first question they asked me uh
and
you know there's a kind of immigration
parties that when you want to settle in
france so the first question is why are
you coming to france and that was my
response pascal is on top of my music
and they said that's a perfect answer
you've come to the right place because
that's normal
and i love france even more after that
why'd you stay there no one america's
been having the problems that's been
having lately you didn't want to come
back here and start
helping us solve some of these problems
that sounds morally far too grand for me
i stayed there because at a certain age
how selfish of you we needed you the
last two years i understand that and i
feel badly about it but uh you reach a
certain age you just don't want to move
around anymore i hardly like to leave my
apartment
speaking of uh your ex-wives um
playboy uh there's a there's a
little bio over here and can i read a
line for you and maybe set you up for
the next question
about the
you're a critic of
the theory of evolution and it says
berlinsky is a senior fellow discovery
institute center for science and culture
um which is the seattle-based think-tank
as the hub of the intelligent design
movement and berlinsky shares the
movement's disbelief
in the evidence for evolution but does
not openly avow intelligent design and
describes his relationship with the idea
as warm but distant it's the same
attitude that i display
publicly towards my ex-wives yeah that
publicly wasn't my word okay
well everything else was that accurate
you know sort of okay would you unpack
that for us well look i have a world of
admiration for the guys at the discovery
institute because they've done a
remarkable job
in
bringing to the
forefront of biological consciousness
some of the deep problems with darwinian
evolution some of the deep problems in
biology itself it's not just the theory
of evolution there's a great deal that's
mysterious not well understood
imponderable not accessible to theory
yet
and there's some terrifically smart
people who have
essentially made the case that this is a
theory which is
in many ways not in every way but in
many ways
not what it's cracked up to be and i
share that sentiment i wrote a piece
well way before i joined the discovery
institute i wrote a piece for commentary
which is a magazine out of new york
making exactly the deniable darwin it
was called
and uh ever since i've been puttering um
like a small motorboat making
related ancillary criticisms it's not
the forefront of my at the forefront of
my attention right now i mean you can
only spend so much time criticizing
darwinian evolution but it's an
important issue and i think those guys
deserve a world of credit for their
critical stance because it hasn't been
easy i mean the entire biological
establishment
is joined in a spasm of repugnance when
intelligent design is prominently
mentioned undeserved repugnants but
repugnance anyway
the the distance
that you mentioned
is my failure wholeheartedly to embrace
the theory of intelligent design i can't
get over there
i can't get over there when the the goal
post is darwinian evolution i can't get
over there when the goal post is
intelligent design that may be my
limitation it may be just a streak of
contrariness i don't know
but i am not an advocate of intelligence
i've never advocated intelligent design
but i'm deeply sympathetic sympathetic
with it that's quite a different matter
to be an advocate and to be sympathetic
i'm sympathetic with a lot of things i
don't advocate for
if you could
i don't know if it's possible to do it
linearly but if on one side of the
equation is um the theory of evolution
right we came to what theory okay so
evolution i i don't want to debate a
scientist here but on one side of the
linear side of things is
we came from monkeys or primates or you
know
salamanders and fish all that and all
that and then on the complete opposite
side of the spectrum is
uh creationism uh and i don't know if
creationism is different from
intelligent design or if you can just
kind of paint a picture linearly of
where things are in the scientific world
and maybe where you are in this and that
could kind of open up
maybe a further conversation
i rest inscrutably at the middle
affirming neither the left nor the right
but choosing a studied indifference to
both
i think that
there's a very legitimate case to be
made for serious theological
affirmations not a case i'm prepared to
make but it's a serious case i mean it's
been a serious case for the last five
thousand years we've called it history
every culture develops a theology and
with the theology a certain kind of
mythology
and with the mythology very often an
elaborate philosophical apparatus after
all the catholic faith is not
intellectually insignificant it's a huge
body of doctrine and dogma jewish
religion has incredibly
exciting deeply penetrating body of
talmudic interpretation
and i'm sure that the same thing is true
of islam i know much less about islam
than i do about other religions but i'm
sure exactly the same thing is true that
the the koran has been the subject of
intense meditation and speculation
i find myself in the
somewhat
embarrassing position of being very
sympathetic
to all of those theological aspirations
but in my own life being unable
wholeheartedly to participate in them
as i say in one of my books i forgot
where uh i'm a secular jew and i've
lived my life as a secular jew the
jewishness is
inevitable i was born a jew
but the choice of a secular
world the choice of secular ambitions
that's not inevitable i mean many people
renounce a secular life but i am in the
middle of a secular environment i
wholeheartedly participate in all the
moral navigations and the uncertainties
of secular life i embrace secular life
and i'm not about to renounce any of it
at what point did you come to this
conclusion which conclusion the fact
that you're neutral you're staying in
the middle i'm an agnostic i'm
sympathetic for those that you know you
you believe there is a god and those on
the other side evolution you know i i
this i'm kind of staying here at what
point did you come to that conclusion
you know when i was at princeton doing
graduate work
so very early yeah
1964 okay 1965.
uh i was room roommates with another a
very good philosopher daniel messinger
was his name and we had never heard
about darwin's theory i mean all through
columbia college all through a graduate
education at princeton theory of
evolution simply didn't figure figure on
our particular intellectual radar
and one day i i said to daniel you know
maybe we should read that book
and so we both read the book dawn's the
origin of the species and we both came
out came away saying you know
this thing makes no sense this is just
gibberish which part of it we were only
22 at the time please bear that in mind
we had no right to say that but it is
interesting and i'm talking now from a
psychological perspective my own
that i can very definitely point to that
experience
two people reading
the foundational text of the theory of
evolution and both of us coming away
saying this this just doesn't have the
ring of truth to it of course it was
completely unmotivated we had no
justification for saying it i'm
reporting an intuitive experience
because you asked me can i give you a
date yeah
1964.
princeton
that's when i
i felt that
that particular double set of anime
versions and you and you never
went through the process of like you
know how martin luther went through a
phase of you know fighting and arguing
his own argument and
going back and forth you never said
uh
you know maybe i'm wrong maybe
i gotta go do a little bit more digging
to go the other side so and maybe you
did did you from 22 ever
all of a sudden like lean a little bit
more towards maybe there is a god i
think there is a god i'm just trying to
see who god is is it jesus is it this is
it that is which one is no no no no i
don't think no no i just read this three
books here no it's not and you know i'm
kind of oh my god maybe these guys are
making sense to me i'm listening to more
these guys were was it like a pendulum
going back and forth were you going
through it or you just stayed right in
your lane
pendulum going back and forth with me i
i think the gravelman of your question
is uh
did i did i suffer uh
the experience of asking myself with a
certain amount of intensity maybe i'm
wrong
yeah no i i can't recall ever saying
that to me though why
because i felt why that level of
certainty no it's not a level of
uncertainty it seems it's not a level of
certainty it's not a level of
uncertainty it's a level of indifference
and and i have to be as candid as as
it's possible to be
look at my age these questions have a
somber significance they lacked when i
was 22 22 i could say you know it
doesn't matter what i can do i can make
up for it later well the shadows are
getting longer and longer obviously
but i still find myself
emotionally indifferent although
attracted to but emotionally indifferent
to an intense religious life perhaps
it's fear perhaps it's just a
temperamental i don't know and there's a
lot to be afraid of when you commit
yourself to a religious life like
judgment
i'm certainly not eager to be judged
nobody is now pat when you ask him that
question i assume that's something that
you had done on your own you've been
pretty vocal about you were an atheist
at one point and now you i mean you
literally wear a cross you've you've
kind of gone through this
what's your uh you know
no pendulum when armand and i we're
going through you know he's like hey i'm
like dude i'm i'm i don't believe in god
i'm an atheist the life i've lived i
don't believe in god this is when you
were this is i'm 23 years old i just got
out of the army it's like nothing's
going my way i'm like dude just leave me
alone i'm i'm not going to go to this
religion stuff some people need god i
don't need god
and
i would go to different bible studies
and they were all boring to me
because they're all telling the same
exact thing then i went to a bible study
there was three mathematicians one of
them was a professor teaching math in
pasadena the other one was a
a pastor who was all about math and i
relate to that because to me math your
the the great thing about math is you
solve for x what's x and then you kind
of work backwards and you're getting to
an answer right and that kind of becomes
the premise of your life business is
solved for x you want to raise 10
million dollars you want to do this much
top line revenue how many employees do
you need what technology do you need how
much do we need to raise today what do
we need to do with this and then you
kind of solve for that number you want
to sell the business everything is about
software x and as engineering as
exactly and as somebody that is at his
level
and with his
level of humor because you need that
which you don't take yourself seriously
that allows you to
be able to entertain more ideas if you
take yourself way too seriously you're
not going to get to the truth because
you protect your ego so
his
combination is the right ideal person to
want to seek it
because he's not trying to be right he's
trying to figure out i don't know if you
understand what i'm saying he's not
grounded in in his beliefs no he's not
willing to come you want some of these
guys that are debating
they're not debating for the truth
they're debating to prove you wrong and
they're great debaters then there's
those that you listen to you're like
damn this guy is i just believe this guy
i mean he's i don't feel the ego i get
the feeling with you so you're the kind
of guy i like to listen to
because you come across as somebody that
you you know
you don't have a uh
you're not trying to prove your
arguments believe me i'm 100 right this
is what's going that's not you that's
not your prayer that's why i said did he
ever go through the battle of pendulum
say man this guy made a great argument i
read this book by this guy did it ever
flip but apparently it did not or is
there something that we're missing that
you something that you 100
wholeheartedly believe if there's
something that the audience
can kind of grasp and be like all right
this is what this guy stands for other
than hey i don't know what i don't know
is there something that you
totally affirm and stand by
religiously sure
what is that i'm not going to say
how what do you mean you're not going to
say why should i confide the innermost
secrets of my heart
why we have you on here today are you
serious with that everyone has something
everyone has something locked away about
which he has a certain emotional
attitude
but it's a very very little interest to
anyone else
is the question
is there anything about which i'm
certain the answer is sure that's what i
want to know for example i'm certain
that mathematics
to the extent that it's demonstrable is
true
i think there are certain very
sophisticated questions you can ask
about truth and proof and mathematics
but those are not the questions i'm
asking i think the body of mathematical
knowledge accumulated
early part of the 21st century is the
richest body of human knowledge ever
accumulated followed very closely by the
body of knowledge encapsulated in
theoretical physics i'm really certain
those are those are achievements
much less certain about lots of other
things certain about
the existence
as every man is certain about the
existence of certain attitudes
validities
commitments
which make no sense to anyone else
but in answer to your original question
my indifference had a lot to do with
watching the experience of my parents
a lot to do
both my parents grew up in germany
imperial germany and then weimar germany
and they both always said they were
children of the weimar republic
they began
music lessons at the age of six and both
became professional musicians my father
was a concert pianist in central europe
my mother was
an excellent pianist
and they both
reported to me very early in my
childhood their defiance of jewish
orthodoxy how they both told the rabbi
well they just didn't believe in god not
the god of the jewish tradition in any
rate the god they preferred to embrace
was the god of art
especially music and they were heirs to
the entire rich complex tradition of
german
german music musical experience
and they enriched that tradition when
they moved to france and they learned
about the french musical tradition
and the question that always influenced
me in my childhood was watching
this commitment and asking myself is
this an adequate substitute
for a classical theological
understanding of the universe
could some and it's it's by no means
restricted to my parents i think
everyone from that milieu
intellectuals writers artists musicians
attempted from 1910 to 1940 or so to
find a substitute god a substitute
experience which would have the same
compelling moral and intellectual force
as a classical religious experience
toward the end of my life
end of my parents lives
it occurred to me in my life as well the
last stages
that that experiment was a failure
that the god in which they had invested
so much emotional and autistic energy
was not really a substitute at all and
that was a sobering experience
that i realized in the end music failed
them both
it didn't provide what they really
needed
and i think that's a very common
experience when you turn
to
deep powerful currents
and you
try to identify them the way many
contemporary intellectuals do when they
talk about humanism for example
as substitutes
for discarded tradition
the discovery i suspect is almost
inevitable
that the substitute is pretty much like
a sugar substitute
it may taste sweet
but it leaves a very bitter aftertaste
do you you know uh one of our users just
gave his super chat and he kind of said
what i was going to ask you but he gave
scripture behind it which is kind of
interesting
i'd love to know what this user's name
is by the way because i can every time i
say cove 12x12 if you can let us know
who yours i can call you by your first
name or whatever name you'd like to be
called i want to give you that credit
he says taking a position in the middle
is interesting the bible mentions
because you are lukewarm
and neither hot nor cold i am going to
vomit you out of my mouth middle is safe
hot or cold is risky so the way i would
say to someone like you is for someone
do you think um
the position you took
at this stage of your life you can tell
me pat you have no closure thomas screw
you i'm very happy where i'm at and i'm
totally okay with that
do you think you took a safe position
from 22 till today the last 58 years or
do you think
you
you
you
could have gone a little bit deeper to
[Music]
really make the argument stronger
amongst different denominations and
evolut you know evolution
or no you're very satisfied with the
position you took
very satisfied i mean
sure you know what i'm asking well from
a rhetorical point of view i would never
affirm i'm very satisfied that that
is too um
to to vulgar a position even from me
um no i'm not i'm not very satisfied i'm
not satisfied at all but i at the same
time i am not motivated
i don't have that urgency of desire
which would lead me to a full-fledged
religious commitment urgency or i don't
have that urgency or desire is that what
you said i don't urgency of desire of
desire you never had it or you don't
have it current
i don't think i ever had it look uh
mathematical talent is fairly rare
i mean you look at the bell curve the
really really tested people yeah are all
the way off in the right yep
um
the number of people who are genuinely
motivated by a religious instinct i
think is about as rare
it's a fully consuming commitment i
don't disagree
i don't disagree it's a fully consuming
commitment you cannot say
i'm leading a religious life and lead
the life of a scoundrel
it's very difficult
i mean you can you you can lead the life
of a scoundrel and expect or at least
hope for divine forgiveness but it's not
a particularly salutary combination
i think in all the all the areas talent
mathematics talent and our talent music
talent and religious experience
the number of people who are seriously
committed
all the way off on the the right-hand
side of the bell curve
if you go back to the 12th
13th and 14th century
the number of people who embraced
a true monastic life
it's about the same as the number of
people who embrace that life in the 20th
century small per percentage of the
population
it's it's a great mistake to talk about
the christian middle ages as if
virtually everyone is interested in it
was deeply involved i mean there was a
reigning ideology that's for sure well
well you know what it's like the way you
said it made sense like being seven feet
tall and having zero interest in
basketball you're like listen i'm not
interested in basketball i want to do
you know complete different game i'm not
i want to play tennis i don't want to
play basketball so
you know i didn't i didn't mean to say i
don't want to i think it's
like i i certainly
would acknowledge
certain desires certain wants
which are unfulfillable
for example i would dearly love to be a
great great mathematician inscribed in
all the history books having produced a
thunderously magnificent set of
demonstrations it's not going to happen
no matter how much i want it to happen
i think in terms of religious experience
there is certainly some desire there for
a committed religious experience but
it's not going to happen either because
i can't act on it
david uh the basic question i just i'm
curious to know how you answer this
question who is god when somebody says
so david who is god what do you say
well there are a lot of different
answers you can certainly waffle your
head off about a question like that you
can talk about a platinus like access to
ever more refined layers of reality a
god followed by successive
successive superior gods that sort of
thing
i think we're pretty limited we're
limited to a particular tradition which
is the judeo-christian tradition that's
where
um the resonance exists and we
we understand that tradition best i i
know there are
has a completely different conception of
god
the buddhist tradition has a different
concept of god but i can't talk to those
because all i know from those traditions
i know as a matter of scholarship
not intimacy
the judeo-christian god is outside
time and space outside the physical
universe it's not one of those things we
encounter within the universe
it has certain attributes certain powers
which we assign to it i mean this is
theology it's not a matter of a physical
science we're not discovering this
and uh
there are two there are two or at least
three additional doctrines associated
with the question that you just asked
one is the the very old idea that
within human beings there's a kind of
image of god
that is there is a
asynchronous appreciation god for human
beings human beings for god which is
manifested
in art
by the assumption that a human being
somehow
reflects the divine the second
assumption is that the surest path to
intimacy
with the deity lies with it
and that's certainly what the buddhists
say as well that is the
what is within gives you the
the surest most accessible way to reach
the divinity
and the third is a series of
pronouncements about human nature that
are part of western theology
for example the christian doctrine of
fallen human nature
which suggests to get back to your
question that when we talk about god i'm
talking about
people in our position
we talk about god we we're talking about
uh
a theoretical entity and it's just
theoretical because we have no hands-on
experience it's beyond experimental
science
who has an intense personal interest in
moral judgment
and that's an aspect which i think is
severely neglected um when we talk about
god we're not talking about
someone who fulfills a certain
role
in explaining how the universe came
about well he created the whole thing
okay we know that we know that that's a
traditional assumption
but a less traditional assumption
especially in the 21st century it's not
only a creating god it's not only a god
with enormous powers embarrassingly
large powers it's not only an infinite
god but it is a guy and this is the
crucial point it's a god who has a
peculiar interest in our moral nature
and who is prepared for example to judge
us
that's part of the judeo-christian
tradition
the judging aspect and it has been
the foundational stone for virtually
every system of judeo-christian morality
since at least the 5th century bc
very much neglected
because the question is wide open when
you take that foundational stone away
you just yank it away
and you eliminate
the idea of the universal system of
judgment
judging human beings for their acts
during their life
um what's the result
what happens to society when you take
that foundational stone away this has
been
a question that i think is has been
pertinent since at least
1820 1830 when the great movement of
secular liberation from christian
doctrine
began to accelerate
and spread to every corner of
every corner of europe in the united
states
we're talking about a 200 year old
process secularism is not just the last
10 years it's a long complicated
tradition
and
we are living in a secular society it's
absolutely obvious we're not living in a
society where people are consumed by the
thought of judgment
or that they're proposing in any way to
put inhibitions or restraints on their
desires
or to conform in any way to
whatever the code of conduct may have
been enforced in the 18th and 17th and
16th century
who are in fact proposing to make it up
as they go along which i'm afraid we're
all doing
um but when you remove that judgment you
were making a point about what happens
when you remove that judgment what
happens well
it's it's like asking what happens in a
physical system you withdraw the energy
from it i mean the physical system can
look just the way it it did before
but there's nothing doing any work
anymore let's just say it's a piston
with no external source of of energy
driving the piston
well
i i i cannot say look uh it's perfectly
obvious what happens but i can say if
you want to know what happens there is a
correlation between the rise of
secularism and the nature of society
look around look around
uh are people restraining their behavior
are they inhibited
a traditional series of codicils being
enforced throughout the answer seems to
be no secularism seems to allow a great
many things that previously were
forbidden does that just come down to
accountability is judgment
accountability is i mean
something that pat always talks about is
accountability like who's holding the
politicians accountable well you know
the voters but
that's a whole other question but
judgment at the end of the day comes
down to accountability are you going to
be accountable for your actions good or
bad
is that essentially the that's a good
question i think it's very similar to
the question i was raising i mean ahab
said the fear of death is the source of
law the fear of violent death is the
source of conscience
it's a source of conscience because
violent death
you meet death without any preparation
any theological preparations and you're
going to be judged instantaneously
that's a very pregnant remark by by
harps but i think that uh
accountability is another way of saying
look we we're now living in a society
where the essential force behind
judgment
the thing that made it live
that's been progressively withdrawn
there's no point in denying it seems to
me no point in saying well we've we've
recreated
a moral universe in every way uh
comparable to the the moral universe
that we have uh
denied or derided are you a gambler are
you gambling man no do you like gambling
on horses or you know like sports or
anything
you don't play cars you don't play dice
you don't you don't play crabs you don't
play any of that
no really you're missing out man no i
was the reason why i was going to ask
you what would you say
uh uh are you
are you the kind of guy that when you
were 25 years old at a bar you saw a hot
girl
did you overthink it in your mind and
say you know i don't know if i want to
go talk to her because what if she says
no or were you kind of like i'm just
going to go talk to her you took the
risk and you spoke to her neither
neither what did you just sat there and
she came to you that's right we're not
part of that league
so you had life easy this so even before
tinder you were tinder so they were
you were tinder do you know what tinder
is no believe me they made it after you
tinder is like a dating site in america
dating app yeah yeah it's a dating app
that guys used to swipe right to get to
but but going going back i don't think
you needed it though but going back to
you
your personality is not at all risky are
you like the guy that hey let's go jump
off that cliff you're like i don't want
to jump off that cliff
of course it's risky
risky which risks am i prepared to take
no well no okay so then no because to me
marriage is risky having kids is risky
going into business is risky moving to
paris is risky to a different all
life is risky right taking a position
with faith is risky deciding to do
almost anything today is risky right so
look i understand the position of
assuming formlessness which means
never like hey you guys i i understand
your position i disagree with this but i
understand this position but i disagree
with this and i kind of stay here that's
a safe
not risky position but you also don't
create enemies
so so you kind of stay in a place where
enemies are not being created but oh
you'd be surprised how are you making
enemies so who are your enemies i don't
i don't see people this like even when
your debate with hitch on sitchins was
very respectful and he wasn't it wasn't
as typical he was more vicious towards
his brother than he was to you you guys
had a very nice debate
we had an extremely pleasant debate
don't forget he was terribly ill at the
time i don't think he had the energy or
the vigor really to
do a full court press i don't think so
it was a one hour it wasn't a three hour
i i it was a one-hour debate isn't that
kind of like
not the point of the debate to have a
nice pleasant debate
it depends whether you're dealing with a
man at the brink of death or not a lot
depends on that
i mean if he had been indisposed with a
headache that would have been one thing
but he was dying of cancer and that
changed all the parameters at least it
did it for me
i was in absolutely no mood to attack
him
got it pat you're asking about risk for
a reason yeah i want to go to that i
wanted to elaborate on that i wanted to
unpack that uh
the question of he you come across as
a guy that would be the risky guy you've
taken bigger risks in your life at this
phase of your life at 80
do you sit there and say well like
inside when you're by yourself nobody's
around you're sitting at a coffee shop
in paris you're having your nice
croissant and the same waitress is
coming to you and you're speaking to her
and you're reading the paper or whatever
book you would be reading and you're
saying
okay david we kind of got a risk and
take one of them what do we want to do
is it going to be jew is it going to be
christian is it going to be lds are we
going catholic are we going to go muslim
let's take it let's pick one of them i
got a 20 chance
you know i'm gonna go baha'i because
baha'i welcomes all the religions you
don't think about it like a little like
pascal's wager isn't it i mean that's
the question you really asked me when i
accept pascal's waiver what is pascal's
wager pascal 17th century he had a
wonderful theological argument about
commitment
commitment to god belief in god he said
look what do you lose
what do you lose
if you commit yourself to god and you
live a
god-fearing life
and god exists well that's a terrific
benefit you've come out ahead of the
game and if he doesn't
exist what have you lost he lost nothing
in game theory that's called a dominant
strategy no matter what it's better to
believe in god
if you don't believe in god and he
exists you're in for an awfully hard
time god and if you don't believe in god
and he doesn't exist well
nothing changes so why is that a bad
approach i don't think it's a bad
approach at all
i think it's an excellent approach and
everyone i've talked to
when i translate that argument into
practical terms agree yes
i accept pascal's wager he was right and
he was right that doesn't mean that the
argument
but you're saying he's right but you're
not willing to accept pascal's weight
yeah but that's the limitation of an
argument you know there are many
arguments i i can consider where the
premises are true the conclusion follows
logically but it doesn't mean anything
to me you'd be a very hard uh
impossible but person to put on the uh
that's but no i trial i i i hate to use
this
angle on what i'm saying
i can see at 20 taking that position i
can see at 30 taking a position
it's like i look at my when i you're my
dad and you are the same age except you
are
older than my dad by nine weeks he's
april 10th you're february 5th both of
you guys are in 1942. he just had a
birthday both of you guys just turned
80.
um
you you like
like you know spending this week with
our guys and we're talking about
leadership and all this other stuff and
each decade i asked myself different
questions and in that decade that
question was the most important question
do you know what i'm saying like
when you're teens you're asking
man you know whatever the question may
be in your teens you know when can i
grow up
when am i going to grow when am i going
to be cool when am i going to be have a
girlfriend when can i go whatever
questions you ask okay am i going to get
a job am i going to do okay in your 20s
you ask different questions in your 30s
you ask different questions in your 40s
you have different questions
certain questions are constant right
what's my purpose why am i here what am
i doing what do you want me to do what's
what am i supposed to do how am i
in the right position i'm at right now
am i in the career certain questions are
going to be constant right
but certain questions as you age
the weight gets heavier and it gets more
important to you at that age than it did
a decade or two or three decades ago i
think that's undoubtedly true well what
is the question that's the heaviest for
you at your age because you just turned
80. so i only can tell you what's the
most heaviest question of my age but
what is the heaviest question at your
age being 80. i don't know what it is to
be 80. i only know what it is to be 43.
the heaviest question heaviest
inevitably possess people my age
digestion health
social security those aren't the
questions you're talking i'm not
by the way that's also good for me to
know because
you know i'm talking to a guy when i was
in my 20s i'm trying to figure out if i
want to get married or not because i was
actually contemplating even ever getting
married i enjoy my own company i don't
know if i want to get married so i had
to really
make sense of does this marriage thing
make sense for me maybe it does for
other people maybe it doesn't for me it
was a very difficult question so i'd go
around asking people the questions and
then finally i came down to a point of
no matter who you married there's a risk
and it's a risk i'm willing to take and
here's how i'm can hedge my risk but no
matter who i'm married there's going to
be a risk right and then one i'm
listening to this a husband and wife who
in their 60s
late 60s and then i'm listening to this
husband and wife who just got married in
their 20s and i'm listening to this guy
that's early 20s single than somebody
that's divorced in their 40s and they're
all talking about marriage
and relationship
and
eventually this 68 year old husband and
wife says you know when i was in my 20s
30s i thought it was all about sex and
let me tell you what happened then
health happened then this happened then
health happened to me
and i was you know
health happened to my wife first and i
was complaining to her because my wife
couldn't have sex with me for nine
months
and then nine months later the moment we
could have sex then health happened to
me and i felt so embarrassed because i
judged her so much and then you're like
oh interesting so maybe one day you're
gonna go through some of these things
with help so i learned as a man as i'm
aging right i'm trying to learn from you
set those questions aside
what are some heavy questions that you
know get you thinking at this age you
lived a pretty good life i can complain
certainly not
or i could complain but i shan't um
i think the question
the really heavy questions are sorrowful
questions at my age
and
one of the experiences of anyone who has
lived the kind of life that i've lived
is the discovery that
inexorably one has
put a certain distance between
what one is doing in my case writing
and the audience one hope to see
that is the separation begins the minute
you publish something you attract
certain readers
you repel other readers that's a normal
point of equilibrium
the further you progress in any kind of
literary life
on the one hand you may if you're lucky
cement a reputation and
achieve a certain loyal readership but
inevitably you discover that
thrill of reaching an audience
is disappointed because
you are inevitably writing for the past
that at my age i can no no no longer be
a fresh voice and therefore no longer
attract new readers
that's exactly how it should be
why because of your age you're saying
people are going to be less interested
they are less interesting
that's not the case for bernie sanders
nobody gave two craps about him for
decades and all of a sudden of the past
five ten years he's the you know one of
the biggest
lucky bernie do you think that's luck i
don't know that's conviction and hard
work
but continue i'm curious it could be a
combination but i think every writer has
the same experience that at a certain
point even philip roth
uh at a certain point
that vivid intense relationship with an
audience that every writer imagines is
out there palpitating waiting hanging on
your every word that disappears
and i certainly feel that in my own case
i'm not complaining i have readers
that's not the point
but in the larger sense i've lost an
audience
and everything about me
is suggestive
of anachronism that is a time before the
present time and again that's inevitable
one can be at the pre in the present
completely in the present only
at a certain age the age of discovery
say from 15 to 30 or 15 to 35.
so when you talk about um what are some
of the deeper aspects of being 80 early
middle aged as i remarked earlier
that sorrowful discovery that hey look
you are about to begin the process of
outliving your time
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with that but it is not a joyous
experience that discovery
neither should it be terribly sorrowful
it's sorrowful but it shouldn't be
terribly sorrowful
they're compensations
have kids sure how old are your kids
my daughter is she was born in 68 and my
son was born in 73. how did you raise
your kids religiously religiously i'm
asking
in no way
you didn't you said you're secular
jewish but you didn't celebrate hanukkah
rosh hashanah nothing nothing garnished
and did they celebrate christmas
american holidays well it's inescapable
you celebrate christmas because you take
off from well you said hey by the way we
are jewish you don't really think i
think that the fact that we were jewish
was imprinted on us vividly by my
parents
by the holocaust by the events of
history there's no escaping that no
desire to escape it either
but in terms of again of a religious
life mm-hmm
not even a suggestion and your kids knew
your parents oh yeah and your parents
fled germany right at the height of the
whole fled uh fled germany in 1932 but
for france okay which is a big mistake
right well this must have some bearing
on your religious
views and your parents religions views
you said that they prayed to the god of
music
or they are prayed or you know they
believed in the god of but
i know a lot of like i'm jewish i've had
family grandparents aunts and uncles
that died in the holocaust and
i always find it there's so many jews
that say i could never believe in god
again like they killed my entire family
killed everyone i know and there's some
jews that somehow become more religious
and they cling to that
what
you know what affected the holocaust and
everything that had you're from germany
in the 1940s
your family was there what effect did
that have on your religion and then how
did that trickle down to your kids
because your kid's not having any
religious basis there's got to be
something tying this all together you've
got to pay more attention to what i'm
saying i didn't say my children have no
religious basis they grew up as jews as
i grew up
they had no religious education which is
quite a different matter they never went
to temple
never went to temple they had no bar
mitzvah no bar mitzvah i did they didn't
okay you see you see the
tradition undergoing a gradual
dissolution which i think is
characteristic of the jewish experience
liberal judaism
um
my parents
regarded the holocaust as a confirmation
of their jewish identity my father
always said the nazis taught me i was a
jew
and he was right
but that doesn't mean he rediscovered a
religious faith that meant he
rediscovered the fact that he was a jew
my mother was a jew the family was
jewish
culturally
far more than culturally
being jewish is not a cultural
phenomenon not at least it's more than
that it's a deep continuity of
historical experience and historical
memory
my grandfather perished nauseous
my mother never got over that and
[Music]
nonetheless
my parents effort my talking about my
parents effort to give me a religious
education didn't succeed i did have a
bar mitzvah i still remember my bar
mitzvah prayers
but uh
the sad truth of the matter is i found
it all
excruciatingly boring
and i still do
i can attest to that i'm not about to
spend a whole lot of time in a temple
[Music]
what are your kids now what are their
faith now or are they practicing or
they're similar to you
we're all secular
all second deeply secular and we have
all of the vices but all of the virtues
of a secular identity that is we all
in some way believe that uh we're
self-created
that the most important thing uh in our
lives collectively is the autonomy of
personality
that the personality exists
in order to be satisfied
that our desires have an intrinsic value
that are quite independent of what other
people believe
i think uh both my children and i
certainly appreciate the fact that to
achieve certain things
there's a
a great deal of discipline involved i'm
not talking about hedonism
uh the desire to lead a life such that
you're having a good time all the time
i don't think anyone believes in that
i live in south beach there might be
some people that disagree with you
south beach florida i guess yes yes
certainly there are people prepared to
say it
but
i know very few people very few
satisfied headness over the age of 30.
the declaration that you live to have a
good time all the time it becomes very
wearying after a while
but uh secularism imposes some severe uh
restraints on how you live
i mean you cannot rely
to an extent to the extent that it was
possible to rely say in the 17th or
early 18th century
uninstitutional authorities
that at every step of the way guide your
footsteps
secularism is the prospect of allowing
human beings to create themselves anew
in each generation no question about
that and sometimes it's very difficult
sometimes it's painful sometimes it's
exhilarating but
as far as i can see we are all in the
position of someone
in a lifeboat
uh wondering whether it would be
more practicable to sail the seas
in an ocean liner well we don't have an
ocean liner anymore we've got the
lifeboat
secularism if you will
and that has to uh that has to be enough
we're always in the process of
fiddling with a lifeboat changing the
orlox wondering whether we should be
sitting in the front or in the back but
fundamentally we don't have access to an
ocean line or that majestic ocean liner
of faith that has pretty much
disappeared do you envy people of faith
no
and why is that
what should lion beat them for so what
do you think comes after life
i have no idea
and no idea and not even something
you've thought about u2k the body breaks
down it's gone because some say
no no i'm not committing myself to a
view
that uh there is no possibility of
experience after death i have no
privileged insight into that and no one
else does either
certainly the fact that every single
society in recorded history has had some
sort
some form of intense speculation about
the afterlife is significant because
it's a deeply
a deeply uh
essential part of human nature to
entertain those convictions
but again
all i can say is
i'll know soon enough
please come back and visit us i sure
will you've got to give me your portable
what what do you think what do you think
is the
uh uh do you have a son or or you said
73 right 73 he's born 73 she's 68 yeah
okay so the son that's 73 he asks you
that uh what do you think is the purpose
of a man in like what is my purpose what
am i supposed to do like if you were and
i know you're going to say to each his
own everybody's different
some it's being this someone's being
that like
what is my you know
what what what purpose do i serve in
this world what am i supposed to be
seeking in life why am i here well if i
if i'm your son and i ask you the
question what do you tell them well i
think i think like many other questions
that are being asked today especially
in social media
um the question is ceremonial modern is
substantive
i don't think i've ever had a
conversation in which my son would pose
the question what is my purpose as a man
in life
um you only have one sentence a few more
if he would oppose that question i would
say hey dumbo look at your grandfather
imitate that
in fact i think i've said exactly that
your grandfather is a model of what a
man should be
why
because unyieldingly tough resourceful
highly intelligent honorable
fought in the foreign legion got my
mother out of germany got my mother out
of france crossed the pyrenees on foot
made a new life in the united states
and
was enormously proud of the fact that he
was one of the few jews in 1940 to face
the germans with a sub-machine gun in
his hands that's enough to be respect of
course salute at the highest level yeah
yeah so that's if my son were
to ask the question how do i be a man
imitate your grandfather
uh david so remember how i asked you the
question what are some of the heaviest
questions at this age where you're at
what what are some things some strong
convictions you had in your 20s 30s 40s
50s 60 whatever you pick it that now
it's kind of like you know yeah it's not
that important
you know i used to think xyz was so
important it's really not that big with
you that's a that's a very good question
except for the the concluding part i i
don't have many where i say it i was
like you were 60 or in the 1960s in the
90s
okay
um you've got to remember i was not a
baby boomer i was born in 42 so i was
three years older than the generation
to which i was exposed in the classroom
and
i have to say my own defense i was very
suspicious of the 1960s although i
participated enthusiastically and i
encouraged my students to rip up their
draft card while keeping mine pristine
god forbid i should go to jail for my
convictions
um
and
when i heard in 1964 the rolling stones
painted black which was a
very popular song of the 19th early
1960s i realized that the sexual
revolution was imminent
it was about to break loose and
didn't take a whole lot of perspicacity
to realize that
but i must say that all of those
impulses
hedonistic impulses
which seem to make so much sense destroy
everything rebuild everything on a
peaceful sexually enlightened basis the
hell with the family the hell with
commitments the hell with patriotic
concerns
simply develop your own sensibility and
live as gloriously as possible in the
satisfaction of any desire no matter how
vagrant remote or degraded that was part
of the 60s and it came to catastrophe
the 60s did not end well we did
incredible incalculable damage to
american society in the 60s and i
watched it all happen i was far too
jejune or
even stupid to recognize it in front of
me even my objections to the vietnam war
were pure isle
and i thought i thought the vietnam war
was a catastrophe because i was 1a
i certainly wasn't about to go off to
vietnam to see my own ass blown off that
was out of the question
my father did not approve of that
attitude
he did not approve of that attitude
he didn't say anything but
you know every son can feel a father's
disapproval
um
he thought there was something
scandalous about not being unwilling to
defend your country by joining the
military
looking back i'm not really prepared to
make a judgment to this day i don't
think the vietnam war has received the
kind of scholarly attention
that it really does deserve it's too
early i mean the vietnam war ended in
1973-1974 it's going to take a hundred
years before we really understand
the wars indo-chinese wars of succession
and don't forget they began in 1945 the
french were chased out then the
americans were chased out
but i do think that in
1962-1963 and this remains an abiding
conviction
not quite an answer to your question but
perhaps illustrates the nature of the
question that no american president
could have done anything other than what
kennedy and johnson did do
i think that's that's true and that's uh
a very curious point because it puts the
entire structure of the anti-war
movement in a different perspective
i have a lot more respect now than i did
in the 60s for my father's attitude
about
honor demanding a willingness to serve a
lot more recently i got a lot of respect
for your for your father's uh a level of
appreciation as a patriot to what this
country probably gave him and his family
where he oh for sure
you have no idea oh it's honorable to
have that mindset
totally honorable but go back to the
question i actually want you to put some
energy into this one here and think
about it because i want to learn from
you
what are some convictions you had early
on and i get 60s as one of them that was
great give me another one what are some
convictions you had
where now
it's like yeah i don't know why i
dwelled over that it wasn't that big of
a deal
seems to me to be honest that the
questions over which i intensely dwelled
were that big of a deal
the nature of family life the nature of
marriage the nature of commitment i
don't think those could properly be said
to be not that big of a deal i think
they were very much a big deal so
whatever you spend a lot of time
thinking about ended up being very
important issues that you spend a lot of
time thinking about
you mean very important issues to me or
very important issues to you i'm just
trying to learn from you
yeah yeah i think the fact that you
dwell on certainty i mean obviously
there's psychological states where it's
unwholesome and unhealthy morbidly to be
attached to certain ideas just don't go
anywhere they spin
but if a man says i've spent a lot of
time thinking about that a lot of time
involved in the emotional discontent
these thoughts provide
that's a pretty good indication that he
thinks they're important don't you think
i do uh um i do david when your audi
when you walk in the streets and
somebody identifies you or somebody sees
you and oh my god i've read your books i
read this and
you know
you help me dot dot dot
what is the most common thing you hear
from people who are fans of yours who
have read your material who have
followed your philosophies
what did you inspire them to
do well i think that the people who
actually break the privacy barrier to
come up to me and there haven't been
many trust me uh once or twice i've been
recognized in the streets and that's
about it but but i'm talking about even
in
when you're giving speeches i'm talking
about you're in a university you're
giving a talk or you're out of debate
and somebody comes up to you and says
david you help me pop up what do they
tell you inspire them to do i think the
the the the formal aspect is um
i'm very grateful for being provocative
and opening up certain questions that i
wouldn't have thought
about myself
and and uh
that happens fairly often thank you for
asking those kinds of questions thank
you for being skepticis skeptical about
that kind of position thank you for
being unskeptical about other kinds of
positions and that happens often
the much more emotionally loaded
complement
or remark is thank you for being so
provocative
and you never know quite what is meant
whether they're thanking you for taking
the flack being a scapegoat
or genuinely thanking you for saying
what in other contexts would be
unsavable
it's never clear you always run the risk
if you're
a man in my position
of coming perilously close to uh
self-parity
you always run that risk
just saying things for the effect
um okay so today with what's going on
you said something he said the secular
movement you said 200 years ago i would
say probably woodrow wilson when they
took bible out of school and people
stopped having to go through some of the
things so for me it would be 117 years
ago maybe but let's just say you're
saying 200 years ago fine
the secular movement where
man
fears a higher power less it's like ah
whatever you know yeah i get it it's
totally fine i'm not you know sure we're
no longer seeing hey you know
president get up and you know give us a
prayer or you go to school and prayer
and you know whether you believe or not
the power of prayer is a way of telling
a kid that hey there's somebody that's
watching over you where you're by
yourself
and you're fearing you don't have to
commit suicide because you can pray and
speak to somebody you are not by
yourself somebody has your back if
i just see the side effects of the
direction we're going without a god
whether it's true or not because you
know the way i look at it is i look at
if you start a country let's just say
you start a country today and the five
is going to start a country you're going
to be the president
i'm going to be a general of a military
he's going to be the one that's checking
everyone's ids to see what uh you know
how good looking they are whatever kai's
going to do different job tyler's going
to a different job
you know
would i build my country on a foundation
of a faith or without it i think whether
people believe in the faith or not to
build it on a foundation of a faith is
going to have a higher chances of doing
better than one not being built on a
certain set of values and principles
because if you don't then people are
going to create their own set of values
and principles so if we're not living by
the same set of values and principles
then i don't have to meet your values
and principles i don't care what you
believe in i don't believe in what you
believe in so i don't have to be
committed to your values and principles
i can do whatever the hell i want to do
i don't care if i earn your loyalty or
your trust or your relationship
then there's that confusion right so
for somebody like yourself because you
know that whole thing you you know you
said this on the last podcast you know
you know strong leaders build good times
good leaders build you know weak leaders
weak leaders build bad times bad leaders
build strongly and that whole thing's
going
do you think your generation
now your fathers do you think your
generation is a generation of strong
leaders
my generation no exceptionally weak
leaders so so isn't is in okay so
so
and i i'm you said that so if that's the
case and that's what you're saying what
do you think is the responsibility of
your generation
to share with maybe our generation so we
don't continue that
you know uh same you know so we can
learn something so say hey you guys got
to pay attention to xyz let me tell you
what's going on right now in the world
specifically in america i've been in
paris for 25 years i've been watching
guys from the outside
the america i'm used to is america used
to be
but today's america's
you guys got to be careful with these
five things you have zero interest in
so that's not a question you're going to
get need to answer you know that no i
don't know that yeah of course i mean
how can i appear gamble a little bit
no how can i appear as a prophet do i
have anything how does that say profit
no but i'm talking look no look for
example okay
say if he's dating a girl okay
uh and he says pat
he hasn't done it yet but if he says pat
this is the first time i'm asking you
for a double date because i want to get
your opinion on it he's never asked me
which means what he's never dated a girl
that's that serious okay he's never
asked me but the day comes when he asked
me
i want to go on a double date i think
this thing's getting a little bit
serious i want to get your feedback on
it okay
so we go
and i meet her
and we walk away and he says so what do
you think
and i had a two and a half hour dinner
with her so i really got a chance to she
sat right in front of me and he sat
right in front of my wife so they're
talking and i'm learning about her right
and uh what do you think
and i say
you know
i would suggest pop-up i really like
their energy i think you guys going to
be good but
you know
i take my time i would give some kind of
counsel as a friend to look at for my
friend my brother right i would give
some kind of a counsel to say here's
it's not necessarily prophetic
but it's more counsel to say
odds wise the odds are son
here's what i would do before you get
married the odds are
if you want to take care of i've been a
financial advisor for 20 plus years
right i don't sit with a client and
saying guaranteed we're going to get you
12 i can't say guaranteed you're going
to heaven guaranteed america is going to
be better i'm asking you based on odds
and your wisdom and your life what do
you tell us what can we be prepared for
because we don't want to get another
bathtub if you want to go out and
introduce me to your girlfriend i'll
give you my honesty
[Laughter]
you want
my wisdom my inexpressible wisdom about
the course of american society yes
and a recommendation for what we
collectively should be doing i have to
discourage you i don't have that
i don't have that why are you playing
safe though david why are you playing so
safe
i don't know why you know you said
something earlier you said uh
you know the level of interest in people
in me right now is you know like versus
what it used to be at this age i'm the
opposite like i enjoy talking to people
when their age starts with an eight
i don't know i can't tell you how many
people have interviewed that's another
respect in which we're different i don't
oh my no you know i'm telling well your
interest is different than my interest
is but my interest is i wanna i wanna
suck as much wisdom from you as possible
because that's the edge of life i pray
for four things courage
wisdom tolerance understanding but
for for for me like i have a painting in
my uh in the club room you know who's in
the club room everybody in the painting
that i have i'm in it plus seven other
people the seven other people that are
in it none of them are here all right
let me ask you a question yes please ask
you a question go forward what kind of
answer would satisfy you coming from my
lips you don't have to be specific just
in general i would tell you what kind of
answer would satisfy me
the answer that is the most uh uh
thought out answer
and as real as possible i'm not looking
for an answer that i want to hear that's
not my style i'm a leader i'm not i'm
not soft i'm strong
i'm looking for an answer for you to
give to say
here's where my generation screwed up
okay
if i had it my way as much as i'm
somebody that's a that's agnostic i do
think
faith plays a very important role or
maybe it's not maybe it's
we got soft because you know we didn't
pay attention to the xyz and we should
have you know i noticed america kind of
went this direction they try to be too
much like europe and they shouldn't have
america was the leader they try to be
like i don't know what it is but
whatever's in your mind to say
here's what i would pass down to you
because
you said the you said weak leaders your
generation i did not say it you said you
said your dad is the epitome of a leader
where your son was born in 1973
if you're going to be a man's man look
at my look at your grandpa and i agree
that's a man's man right but i'm asking
you what can we learn from what you've
seen so we don't screw this [ __ ] up
cause i got four kids i got a ten eight
and a five-year-old and a nine-month-old
you just saw the five-year-old in here
my daughter was in a podcast running
around
i want to learn from you sincerely i
want to learn from you so i don't screw
it up myself all i can tell you is i've
been out of country for 25 years now my
experience has all been centered in
france coming back regarding the united
states
it seems to me on the one hand an
enormous amount of energy is present in
the united states an enormous amount of
exhilaration enormous amount of optimism
strangely enough and at the same time
i can see very clearly they're all
consuming social divisions cultural and
social divisions
all right i see it are you asking me for
a diagnosis and the respect in which my
generation made decisions that led to
this well sure that's inevitably true
the generation that came to power in the
1960s witnessed a collapse of authority
that's unmistakably true a collapse of
political moral intellectual social and
sexual authority and that has
reverberated
for the succeeding 50 years there's no
question about that we're still living
with decisions
made in the 1960s say the period between
1962 and 1971 1972 when tendencies
acquired a certain fixity of direction
but that's not necessarily to say
anything about a generation screwing up
because that inculpates a generation in
something they did deliberately
and i think the
the fundamental facts of the 1960s is
not that anyone did anything
deliberately but they were all victims
of a process of interior collapse not
the first time in the 20th century we've
seen that
i mean you can go to france and
say the
1930s and see a very similar dynamic at
work
so no i don't think it's a question that
my generation
all the baby boomer generation screwed
up
but that
at a certain period of time
a great many contingencies occurred
simultaneously
the wars of indo-chinese succession
preceding a pace no matter what the
americans did or thought socially and
culturally
the assassination of jfk which no one
expected which disrupted the political
continuity of american life
the ascension to power of lyndon johnson
who was a magnificent
domestic politician
but very inexperienced in foreign policy
the progressive aging of a foreign
policy establishment that successfully
fought the second world war and
navigated the cold war with the russians
in the 1950s
the fact that there was an enormous
increase in young people aged 15 to 25
is the result of the end of the second
world war that's why they were called
the baby boomer generation
the fact that every time there's an
enormous cohort population cohort a
bulge in the population
there's bound to be some sort of strife
fraternal strife social strife
because every new generation needs to be
disciplined and domesticated the larger
the generation the more difficult it is
to enforce the authority of the previous
generations all these things came
together in the 1960s
nobody intended that they came together
they come together they did come
together
and we are living with the repercussions
ever since in addition to all that
the 1960s was a continuation of an
historical process that goes back at
least to
the french revolution that is the
increasing secularization
of the social order the withdrawal of
established institutions of religion for
example the catholic church in france
but the protestant clergy in the united
states as well and you can trace it out
step by step
if you look at english poetry from 1820
to 1850 you can see
an ark
1820 you have someone like lord byron
saying the assyrian came down like a
wolf on the fold and his cohorts were
gleaming and purple and gold
and the poem is about the destruction of
the syrian army the pom pom ends the
famine you talk about the famine no the
destruction of sanakari you've got it um
and the might of the gentile on smote by
the sword hath withered like snow in the
glance of the lord now this is a flimsy
poem it's not a great piece of poetry
the date is 1822 and byron could write
in the expectation that every one of his
readers would understand that he was
participating in what was still a
christian society
it may not have been a completely
committed christian society but the
architecture was as plain as the
architecture of notre dame
you go 30 years into the future
it's not a long time
you have matthew arnold writing dover
beach
he says
o my beloved let us be true to one
another for the world which lies about
us like a land of dreams
hath neither really joy nor light nor
life nor certitude nor peace nor health
from pain
and we are on as uh as on a darkling
plane swept by confused alarms of
struggle and flight where ignorant
armies clash by night that's a
completely different world view byron
could not have understood that
he's talking about the melancholy long
withdrawal of faith from the european
continent
30 years you see a change a dramatic
change in the dire patient of european
life
and you can you can continue that right
through to t.s eliot w h auden phillip
larkin
the decline has been
not necessarily linear but it's been
inexorable so all these things play a
role in talking about when i talk about
the generation
that came just after me the baby boomer
generation
i don't think any lessons can be learned
for what are historical necessities
what we see is
a great many contingencies occurring at
the same time roughly the same 10-year
period and then bang
a lot of different trajectories set as
if they were canals
canals dividing the sand
that's very different i can talk until
i'm blue in the face about the
collapse of authority which i witnessed
myself in the universe in a university
setting i saw all the people i respected
deeply for example crumble in the face
of student protests just crumble
i saw that at columbia i saw that at
princeton i saw that at stanford unless
it's tampered but i saw it at berkeley
as well berkeley of course and um
you know you have pig ignorant people
like mario savia savio at berkeley
getting up on top of a car and
denouncing a system which was in every
every respect one of the glories of
american democracy the california
university system
and the university officials i was right
there i watched them say yeah yeah
you're right you're right
bow down low scrape the ground with
their nose
and all that i could think of at the
time and a few other people thinking the
same thing
how dismal to see this great tongue fall
so low as to lick the dust do you think
professors have more
voice today or in the
70s 80s 90s
they've had an unwholesome effect since
the 50s
that is uh the american professoriate
but i think also in england and france
it's true well then let me ask the
question in a different way so the whole
thing with your generation where it's
led to today there's two things i think
about like i think about when i see a an
office or i see a ceo or a business
owner or a leader i just spend two days
with a bunch of patriots and they're
talking about bill belichick and i said
from the first time you played for the
guy when he hadn't won a super bowl yet
this is matt light
to him now who he's won six super bowls
he's known as one of the greatest
coaches of all time if not the greatest
coach of all time
what changed with them did his standards
drop did he get easier to work with
what happened with them you know what
both you know what everybody in that
room said
they said one thing about bill belichick
is his standards never dropped right
that's why he keeps winning because you
have to constantly raise up to its
standards but what the nfl did they used
to be able to do two day trainings and
they changed it in 2011 where you
couldn't do it anymore and belichick
used to train on fridays
no team trained on fridays because you
got a game on sunday why would you train
on fridays you had fridays off your
tuesdays off these guys are like no this
guy was constantly here rob talked about
the fact that for nicest he says i
remember playing in college i remember
playing in high school i remember
playing for miami i remember playing for
new orleans i don't remember what
happened the nine years i was at
patriots because it went like this wow
he said all i know is we won two super
bowls all the other places we didn't win
which means what the standards would
risen so the question comes to you do
you think
do you think there was a element of
the
the
lowering of standards gradually ah it's
okay you know
you don't think that you don't think
standards will drop over the years i
think standards were dropped but i don't
think that was the cause i think it was
the effect what was the cause the cause
was
uh and you i think you have to
appreciate how little we really
understand these great pivotal moments
in history
1961 1962-1963
every
figure in authority had reached a
certain age
not the age of great flexibility but a
certain age and had a certain repository
of wisdom they were confronted by an
enormous group of young people
flaunting
their sexuality their physical prowess
they were confronted
in yates's terms of the young in one
another's arms and it undid them it
unmanned them they didn't know how to
respond they were certainly prepared to
face the nazis all over again ought to
face the communists but to face their
own children
in the luxurian frivolity of sexual
embrace was beyond them nothing in their
training had prepared them to deal with
the rebellion
by their own children and that's what
took place in the 1960s
to 1971 1972 and it's still to a certain
a certain extent taking place right now
i mean after all
the overwhelming impression that united
states affords to any foreign eye
is that every successive generation in
its taste of proclivity desires
abilities ambition seems to be
more infantile than the generation it
replaces
uh certainly if you look at american
music american culture american life it
seems intensely infantile
at least at least from a certain
perspective that began in the 1960s it
began with the collapse of authority if
you're asking me why did these people
allow their own authority to collapse
there's no answer beyond the one i gave
you that certain sites are not meant to
be seen by the elderly and unfortunately
you have a huge population of young
people who happen to be affluent
that's another factor the first
generation that didn't have to retire to
a factory to the field in order to feed
themselves they had disposable a
disposable income they could play at
leisure
the first generation that happened to be
affluent displaying immemorial human
urges simply undid the figures in
in authority throughout american life
and i saw it i saw it with my own eyes
it's a
last question i want to ask and i'm
going to turn it over to you guys and
we'll go to callers it's the last
question i'm going to have with uh
with you on this topic is
which institution do we trust too much
that we should have never given them
that much power and trust universities
okay i agree okay universe tell me what
you unpack that please and when did that
happen when we trusted them way too much
the degree to which the university has
become a democratic institution is a
function of the decision undertaken in
the 1940s and 1950s to open it up to
everyone don't forget before 1940
university education was a very
aristocratic education it was restricted
to very few people
it had protocols of admission wealth was
involved but also intellectual ability
in 1940 1950 there was an enormous
experiment in the united states to
broaden the franchise in effect
um
what was neglected in this is that the
prophesariat
since time immemorial has been kind of a
monastic order
that is the the injunction
placed on
people who want to do academic work is
that yes if you're talented enough you
can withdraw from society you can live a
quasi-monastic life you won't be earning
a great deal but you'll be doing the
work that is necessary for you to do and
you'll be teaching the next generation
again as the as the franchise was
enormously expanded this changed
becoming a professor became a very
lovely racket i know i did
uh you had lots of money lots of free
time you had
an endless panoply of attractive young
people in your audience
um you could do pretty much as you
wanted for four months of the year
there was all sorts of additional
sources of financing available
it attracted an enormous number of
people
who had never had any experience be
beyond the academic world look i went
from bronx science to columbia college
from columbia college to princeton from
princeton to stanford and never once did
i do an honest day's worth of work in
anything beyond an academic setting i
had no idea what work outside the
academic world was
i discovered very soon of course that i
was completely unqualified untalented
when it came to work outside the
academic world but you have a whole
generation
who has not had that experience that
discovery of the limitations of their
academic competence
and of course the result inevitably is
the growth of extremely arrogant
priestly class
perfectly prepared to tell the rest of
us how to live what to do
and beyond the physical sciences beyond
physics and chemistry to certain extent
biology certainly mathematics
very much prone to crackpot theories
very much prone to conspiracy theories
crackpot theories ludicrous ideas about
human nature undocumented unreferenced
assertions of vowels i mean that
versions that make absolutely no sense
in retrospect but nonetheless swept
through the academic world one after the
other
you're not going to make too many
friends and all our professors listening
to this well we'll see
by the way we just had a moment yeah
exactly we just had them just took a
risk yes it took an hour and 31 minutes
for my guest today to take a risk
there's a lot of professionalism
[Music]
direction anywhere you want to go
because callers are waiting about this
is a question that i think that you're
qualified to answer
i'd appreciate an answer uh this has to
do with mathematics religion sure uh
evolution
uh the great um
american scholar philosopher that we
talked about earlier by the name of joe
rogan had a bit back in 2009 he did a
stand-up comedy you know joe rogan
by name okay he says sends his regards
um he had a bit uh or a stand-up special
called um
talking monkeys in space
where he's having a conversation right
you got the title he's having a
conversation with a guy
about his faith
and he uh the guy's like i came from
jesus bro like straight up i'm from
jesus i have faith i came from jesus and
joe goes how do you know so much aren't
you like 30 like how do you know so much
who you know and joe rogan basically
says look uh you know what i do uh i
don't know everything but there's uh i
like to memorize [ __ ] that a lot of
smart people have come up with and i
basically just kind of read what they've
already kind of put together and i just
kind of regurgitate that and one of the
things that they found is something
called the human genome familiar with
this concept the human genome so
basically he says what they found in the
human genome is that we us humans are 96
chimpanzee 96 chimpanzee this is his bit
and he says and sort of jokingly now if
i gave you a sandwich
and it was 96 [ __ ]
and four percent ham
are you willing to call that a ham
sandwich and basically saying we're
monkeys bro we're freaking monkeys
flying through space
and he basically saying that that's the
evolution right there you're a
mathematician is joe rogan right here
and please refute him if he's wrong
there was so many vivid voices emerging
just now i'm not quite sure who's saying
what um the doctrine that uh
are we did we come from monkeys are we
96 percent is there an evolutionary path
from our
simian ancestors to you yeah of course
there is nobody doubts that i know some
people do do that that's what i'm asking
not here okay we're not about it you're
taking a stand and saying that we did
come from apes but that's
uncontroversial well it is though i feel
no so you're taking a stand and saying
that we did come from apes you're wrong
it's not controversial nobody when
pressed will really deny
because you have to endow come from apes
with a certain amount of content
if you mean come from apes by a process
of random variation and natural
selection i'll say wait a second i don't
i don't think that's quite accurate if
you mean to say there's overwhelming
evidence that there are evolutionary
transitions we can walk the human line
back
and actually see
the patterns emerging from both the
fossil record and the paleontological
record
of course of course that's true
there is no evidence that it is anything
other than that
which is perfectly compatible with the
doctrine of creation by the way
how's that because that's
incompatible no evolution and
creationism i thought that's a different
ends of the spectrum it depends what you
mean by evolution if you mean you can
trace your ancestors back and sooner or
later you will run into something that
looks markedly unlike you but
in a certain way
resembles you sure that's
controversial you can do it genetically
you can do it in terms of the fossil
record if you mean on the other hand
that at a certain point something new
emerged
for which we have very little
understanding
that too can be argued for example
although there is a striking sequence
similarity it's it's certainly not 98
it's somewhere in the 80s
and there are a lot of questions about
how those sequences are mapped one to
the other don't forget until very
recently we did not have a complete
human genome
but if you look at
human beings
and you look at our presumptively
nearest ancestors
there's an unfathomably large distance
between us
unfathomably large we are completely
different
we have properties not seen in the rest
of the animal kingdom we have behaviors
not seen in the rest of the
animal kingdom we have a cognitive
apparatus that's not seen in the rest of
the animal kingdom
so on the one hand yes i can
go backwards progressively
chasing
ancestors and saying well there's a line
of derivation that makes perfect sense
no point in disguising that but at the
same time when we reach the stage of
human beings
there's an explosion of very interesting
and very isolated properties both those
things are true
richard dawkins wrote a book
um
and one of the more vivid examples that
i remember from this book i think it was
called
the the the magic of
reality is that what it's called i think
so
um he talks about that if you take a
picture like you talked about your
grandfather or your father your
grandfather if you take a picture and
you just keep going back and back and
back and back and back and back and you
go
thousands of pictures you're going to
run to to like a great great great great
great great great grandfather that looks
like croak magnum man and then if you go
back back back back thousand thousand
thousand pictures pictures pictures
picture pictures you're gonna run into
some sort of ape and then if you go back
back back back back back back to the
freaking beginning picture picture
picture uh fond of smoking cigars or
something or i don't know and the other
question i had was
what are you perhaps in too elevated of
a position to where maybe you get down
in the dirtiness of it and perhaps you
have a religious moment and uh generally
speaking that's my question also the
third is with things like the soviet
union and france where
you had situations where they're trying
to get rid of religion and there was a
counter push against that and religion
isn't uh gone
um and a lot of these are intellectual
pursuits and such for where they push
this
i was wondering what his opinion was on
that and does it lead to sort of a
mindset
where you know you're just going along
with the status quo because i've run
into certain conversations with people
where
you know they want don't want to take a
position
after they um
you know after like if you don't believe
in god perhaps maybe
you're um
you know and what's the point in living
kind of thing for some people and i've
had some conversations with them where
they're borderline nihilistic
what's your thoughts on that well there
are three and a half questions the first
question about an indirect path
is a very interesting question and of
course
every every serious religion has talked
about that or written about that and the
position of the catholic church for
example is crystal clear and it can be
summed up very simply if you behave
as if you believed in god
faith will be given to you
which is an extremely sophisticated and
subtle declaration do i know that that's
true no i don't know that that's true
but i think it might well be true
faith is given to those
who act as if they had faith that's the
first question i think which touches on
questions of indirectness
and i think it's a very penetrating
question because
the direct approach very often proves
fruitless you can't hammer a religious
conviction into someone you can terrify
him pretending but that's not quite the
same thing
the second question if i recall it
correctly
was the extent to which
certain
desperate experiences
can easily provoke a man to
at least the affirmation of a religious
conviction that goes back to the
question we were discussing an hour ago
called them extreme situations the
trouble with extreme situations is if
you push extremity to the limit
they can do one of two things they can
reinforce or create a sense of faith or
they can destroy it completely
i know many people
who entered the concentration camps as
orthodox jews and left despairing
suicidal
by the same token i know some people
who found strength
in their religious tradition when they
emerge from the concentration camps so i
don't think that's a very good piece of
evidence certainly
we all know of the temptation
in combat
and and the aphorism which i think is
quite true there are no atheists in the
foxholes that may well be true i've
never been on a foxhole i can't speak
with personal authority
the third question is
can we say anything intelligent rational
reasonable about the experiences of
soviet russia nazi germany with respect
to
the collapse or undermining of religious
religious convictions as social
institutions
um
and yeah i think we can and i don't
think anyone is ever going to count
lenin trotsky stalin mao adolf hitler as
among the religious leaders of mankind
and there's a reason for that i think
attempts to say that nazism and and
stalinism were themselves
negative nihilistic religions those are
unsuccessful they weren't they were
essentially
contemptuous of religious experience
atheistic to the core
um
you know stalin at the end of his life
made a hat may have had some use for
priestly intervention he was a
suspicious man but certainly they acted
all of the totalitarian figures in the
20th century acted as if there were no
possibility of ever being held to
account for their crimes i think that's
the that's the real issue john do we
have any other callers
yes we have sienna on the phone siana
how are you
hi good evening i'm good how are you
guys fantastic what's on your mind
what's your
question uh first i guess i just want to
say thank you for guys all that you do
uh one question mr belinsky um if the
poorest man has the richest heart is he
really poor
i'm sorry what was the first part of
that she said if the first man has the
richest heart is his
poorest heart sorry the poorest heart is
safe
we can't hear you by the way your audio
is very low that's why
oh if the poorest man has the richest
heart is he really poor
oh yeah
no question about it but is he rich in
something beyond
what what the question is addressed to
it's always possible but i think that um
almost a universal experience of
religious life is that there is a
level of deprivation which makes
concentration on anything
beyond material sustenance very
difficult
so you can say if a man is poor he may
nonetheless be rich in wisdom which
certainly true
but he remains poor
it's bad news i we've got some bad news
for you that man is still poor i don't
know if it's a man
marion he's still a poor man
financially but let's go to the next one
uh john yeah we have michael on the line
michael how you doing
how's it going patrick david um
what's what's on the line
awesome uh my question is um
for the for the man of the hour um do
you and as well as everybody else in
there um do y'all believe math was
invented or created
well
is there a big distinction between being
invented and being created i'm not sure
usually it's posed as did human beings
create mathematics or did they discover
mathematics
is is that the question
it's just it's just the question of
do you think that humans invented math
or it was was math just always
from the beginning of the universe was
it always it said you know it was a
difficult question because um
they're they're fairly fairly
interesting philosophical arguments but
my commitment would you say it's
obviously this is not a human invention
it has no properties like so god created
it i didn't say that
[Music]
i didn't say it
and you know his faith has increased but
your faith has increased in the last
hour no it hasn't increased at all
the same robust level it was when i
entered the discussion but the point is
we have a very difficult problem talking
about mathematics because these are
objects that are obviously not physical
the number one is not a physical object
neither is the number seven
and um they don't seem to be in time in
quite the way we want objects of
contemplation to be in time doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense to say
well the number three
came into existence in 1932
[Laughter]
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense you
can say that they're philosophers who
will say anything
but they do not elicit a whole lot of
respect by that kind of declaration well
if it didn't come into existence
at any particular time does that mean
that they're eternal in some sense
well yeah
i think i think it does although i can't
tell you what being eternal means since
there's a conflict between the view of a
mathematician and the view of a
physicist a physicist will say space and
time arose space and time arose with the
creation of the universe at the big bang
before the big bang on one theory of
cosmology there was nothing
and not even the laws of mathematics
that's a view i find personally
repugnant
intellectually unaccommodating but there
it is some people believe that
but as far as the invention of
mathematics goes i don't know of anyone
who studied mathematics seriously thinks
this stuff was all made up
not a soul good question i have a
question as well uh you talked about as
being a
secular jew in terms of that over time
kind of the the religion erodes and it
kind of goes downwards uh do you think
that the role of
uh religion has what that has played in
history has been a overall good thing or
a bad thing
god you guys are unbelievable these are
incredibly difficult questions i just
had occasion to write a long essay about
the british empire
was the british empire from 1600 to
1949 when it finally ended or 1960 when
all the the various colonies gained
independence was it a force for good or
a force for bad
and you look at it you study it
seriously you studied it historically
you come to the conclusion it's too soon
to tell
well you think it's any easier
to make the claim with respect to the
roman empire say from the age of
augustus to the fifth century when the
roman empire in the west collapsed
historians are still enraged with one
another because one half of the
historical community said we'll say ah
the roman empire was rapacious it was
cruel it was monstrous overbearing dr
johnson has a famous remark about the
roman empire these people
lived by stealing from
from strangers and when they ran out of
strangers from which to steal they stole
from one another
that was his view of the romans
on the other hand we have to say without
the roman empire
the entire glorious tradition of western
history would have been aborted
2 000 years ago
so it's a very difficult question to
answer
has the role of religion has religion
been a good thing overall has it been a
bad thing it's been an inescapable thing
it's been a necessary feature of our
existence and we can certainly point to
good things and bad things obviously so
the good things
and the bad things
don't quite get to the essence
of the moral question we were talking
about an hour an hour and a half ago
whether without the structure
of divine authority
a completely moral
or acceptable social life is possible
that's a question that we have yet to
answer so i got so since
maybe our booker didn't manage
expectation he should have said we only
asked tough questions but i got a
question for you i think you may like
and it's not going to be complicated go
ahead do you like ice cream
yeah okay then so you can't tell us all
we do is ask you tough questions that's
a very spiritual experience for some
people when they have the right kind of
ice cream john give us a last caller
uh before this man decides to increase
his faith and become a christian pastor
by the time we're done watch david move
from france to fort lauderdale build one
of the biggest churches here
and thousands of people show i'd go
he would pray he's probably more likely
to build a church in south florida with
you church hang on do we have a caller
do we have we have one last caller yes
cameron's on the line cameron cameron's
back cameron how you doing
good uh one question do secularists
credit religion for promoting the golden
rule
do unto others as others as you would
have others do unto you yeah
yes that's what you're talking about yes
um
depends who you're listening to i i
think the golden rule is kind of a folk
apothem i mean every culture somehow
discovers it some assign it to
to a theological province some author
assign it to just good common sense it
appears almost in every culture
it doesn't appear from the beginning you
go through
the greeks for example they had no use
for the golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you well that's okay except for
the slaves except for women
except for a small social circle
the romans also had difficulty with
these kind of essentially christian
doctrines not until the third and fourth
century as christianity achieved
dominance in the roman empire were these
sentiments taken for granted as part of
accumulated wisdom
but yeah every culture has has
encountered the golden rule i would be
very skeptical about saying it's
uniquely a religious principle
we got four more minutes if you got any
questions are you good just before i
joined the church in fort lauderdale i
wanted to know if you had any
definitive strong
opinions on
jesus christ
yes meaning
what are you
willing and definitively able to say
about the life of jesus
that one time you guys had sushi
together
um
meaning he existed check i i think this
is born from the virgin mary i don't
know was he resurrected too soon to tell
what can you definitively say about
jesus you've just said it
okay that's it that's it so i answered i
mean look how could you be asking a
secular jew for his personal opinion
jesus was a jew so you know maybe
there's a lineage if i go back and back
and back and back to photographs i could
see a picture of jesus doubtful doubtful
so you don't you do not think jesus was
the son of god based on math no
no i mean look when i say i'm a secular
jew i really mean church i i'm not
committed to christian doctrine no i'm
not you don't have to be a believer i
don't believe in the trinity either but
so do you believe in moses do you
believe in abraham there are figures
from the bible for which i think there's
very good reason to suppose they existed
in some some fashion or other certainly
moses isn't historically a tested figure
no matter what freud had to say about it
and jesus is also a reasonably attested
historical figure but without whether i
believe in say the trinity or the
doctrine of ins uh
insi
insubstantiation
or whether i believe in original sin or
whether i believe in
the mystery of faith or any of these
questions or have a personal
relationship with jesus no okay well
before we wrap up the podcast i think we
should all join hands and pray and bow
and maybe we just david final words give
us give us final words here before we
wrap up about what whatever you want to
talk about tell us what
tell us uh
have these
tough questions the challenging you
faced you know the last hour and 50
minutes
uh has have we solved any of the major
questions and problems in the world
today
any of the major questions and problems
in the world today well you've certainly
solved the problem of how best
i might occupy myself between four and
six o'clock today
and very pleasant conversation i think
that should be enough for the rest of us
and you really your main outcome was met
people now know
you have a very good style of how you
dress absolutely so
that's been established but uh it was
great having you on i enjoyed you being
a good sport and taking the questions
and a push back back and forth was
fantastic i hope the audience enjoyed it
just as much as we did tomorrow we have
uh ethan supply yeah yeah actor remember
remember the titans boy okay fantastic
looking for american history he lost
like 80 pounds or something
not even 80 pounds more than 80 pounds
like 180 pounds yeah he's jacked now
yeah he's jack now so we're excited
about having him on he's what jacked
very special in french means
jacques like in shock
but we'll be back same time same channel
9 a.m nice day today's what today's
tuesday today's today's wednesday that's
right today forgive pat he's been
traveling i don't know i just got back
like a couple hours ago we'll be back
tomorrow or friday
tomorrow morning gang we'll see you guys
tomorrow night and take care everybody
bye-bye bye bye bye
all right
you